hi everyone it's jerry let's have a look
at a game from the 1960
leipzig olympiad
a round 8 game
bobby fischer has the black pieces in
this one
his opponent is rene latelier-martiner
international master
and five-time chilean champion he won
that title
in 1957
59 60 64
and finally in the same year fisher
would become
world chess champion
1972.
so there's some nice instructional value
from this brief game
uh
if you're uncomfortable facing an
opponent who likes to amass a big pawn
center right now fisher's facing
uh
three white pawns and soon
as we'll see in this game a fourth is
invited if you're unsure how to cope
with
such an approach such an approach by one
of your opponents i think there are a
lot of useful tips
packed into this one game
how exactly should you
undermine it
okay
castles in this game
this is an invitation for
you know
fisher is inviting white to enter his
house with this fourth move
castles not the most common move most
common is d6 which cuts out
this e5 move e5 is bad
in this case because white would have to
make an uncomfortable move after queen
takes queen right you go on castled
knight g4 black is already winning
or you demote the knight neither
is fun for white and this pawn already
experiences some pro some problems
all right can it even be maintained
right
you try to defend you can maybe knock it
out
okay bad news for white
meeting d6 with e5 so
fischer castles in this game white jumps
at the opportunity to play e5 why not
pawn on e5 can't be captured let's do it
the knight has to go back
this is what fisher was welcoming with
castles on move four can't go to the
edge that's going to be painful knight
will be dead
so
back rank the knight goes
f4
so here we are what's the approach
we're staring at four big white ponds
step one is what
step one is to view this furthest
advanced pawn the one that's in your
house
as
an invader we don't we don't want that
guy in our house so
some pressure on it with not just any
pawn the d6 pawn and we could we could
put pressure on it with d6 or
uh excuse me f6 or d6
d6 we're going with the
less committal of the two
why is this one less committal well
we're not
making our king side
weakened right
we're not opening up a diagonal towards
our king maybe at a later stage f6 can
surface
but right now far and away best is d6
we're immediately putting pressure on
the e5 pawn
some devel uh development by white with
bishop to e3 this does
lend some support to the white queen
in the event of black now releasing
the tension
which is to say capture an e5
white will be able to take with the
d-pawn and if we have the exchange of
queens in this case you'll note it's not
uh it's not as uncomfortable decision
for white anymore right
you have to go with the knight or the
queen
you have the convenient recapture and
deployment of the rook on an open file
okay
note
the tension in this game than the timing
of certain captures
not this just yet first
we're undermining the center further c5
hits it appears that
uh white
likes to be black doesn't have enough
support for that
something you need to keep in mind is
uh probably after
if you're gonna go with fisher's
approach
and play castles on move four
you probably have to have in the back of
your mind that okay
white's to have a big pawn center
potentially
and i need to be okay
with
variations
that
invest one of my own pawns in order to
dismantle my opponent's central
structure i may have to give upon in
order to
mobilize my pieces or demote my
opponent's pieces or
break up this big pawn on e5
that's what happens in this game fischer
is is okay with giving up a pawn
c5 on board
d takes c5
uh move played in the game
you can also go with this one
you can respond as
you can respond to these two moves in
the same way
knight c6 so if this one
white is giving up the e5 pawn
for the d6 pawn and we can continue to
develop there's now going to be a a new
focal point
d4 now that the e5 pawn isn't here and
this is
really problematic for white
right as an example if you
try to just win the pawn on e6 this is
already winning for black
look at the development
y king is in the center open e file it's
going to be an accident on d4 maybe a
fork
knight d5 is no problem queen e6
no forks on c7
bad news for white to approach it in
this way
okay in this game it's d take c5
we don't capture neither direction
because we
we care we care about our queen
knight c6
development
c takes d6
e takes d6
and white plays knight to e4 so
there are some variations here i'd like
to share
the first one is well if white captures
like this
black is considered winning already uh
look at the development right this this
pawn that was boxing out the night is no
longer there after this capture
the knight will gladly recapture
now there's this
look at the minor pieces
beautiful
huge lead in development well worth the
pawn
investment
okay
knight f3 is another possibility how
exactly to approach this one
initially i thought to myself
uh
i i believe the first thought that
crossed my mind when i was you know
playing around with the different moves
of this game is well if the knight goes
here can we not go ahead and capture on
this square and that's not true
because
we would have white initiating this
capture now the knight has to
run back to recapture and then this is
not
a good variation at all for black
so
no capture here if this move
bishop g4 i thought
was a move to you know undermine the
knight but considered even better
is to immediately go to e6 and now that
the queen is defended we're now ready to
go ahead and
chop away on
this e5 square
so just something worth noting this is a
very common move you may see instead of
the move played in the game
i'm moving an already developed piece so
this is already kind of iffy
uh for white this is where white starts
to go astray
he has a he has an eye on this d6 square
from here we have bishop f5
and the reply is knight to g3
if white goes ahead and captures on d6
we would go ahead and capture the knight
if pawn takes pawn this is inviting rook
to e8 that's bad news it's reading as a
-7 already
should not be afraid of this past pawn
this is
this pawn isn't going anywhere white's
probably going to get checkmated in a
handful of moves it feels
with the development of the black pieces
if queen takes knight in this position
you can go ahead and exchange queens and
then pick up one of the two pawns you're
down
capturing on b2 but considered best here
and i think this is the
uh
one of the more instructive lines to
share with you
is and
a nice approach in this in this case is
to duck the queen exchange
black
has his sights set on this king
uncastled this position is opening up
let's keep the queens on
um
queen to e8
pretty slick move
what is it doing exactly well
avoids the queen exchange opens up this
uh rook d8 move it's gonna it's gonna be
a nice tempo against the queen and also
there's some pin
uh on the on the e
file pawn or bishop one of the two is
is going to be pinned
after knight f3 for example
how do we approach this well
now we go ahead with f6 and look at
this position is cracked wide open
you can't take here the bishop would
fall with check
um
what is f6 doing
trying to get rid of e5 so that not only
the bishop can see
further into the white position
but also
black wants to
liberate the rook
oftentimes it only takes a couple key
pawn moves
in order to
mobilize pieces on the very squares they
they sit
the rook can be activated on f8 with
just pawn play alone
that's what f6 is accomplishing here
you really don't need to go
uh
any further here at the they say
e6 is best rook d a queen here and then
you get the pawn back this is this is
gonna probably be very difficult for
black to defend and you know let me just
take it one move further
still on this theme of undermining the
white pawns
uh the best move here is g5
trying to pry open the f-file or maybe
uh kick the knight to a not so great
square okay i've gone far enough
uh we don't have this capture on d6 but
these are important structures at least
i want to provide a at least some feel
for how you can approach these different
structures that may come about
so in the game it's knight g3
we have this
attack of the knight being met with a
counter attack
the bishop falls back to e6 was that
worthwhile
uh was that worthwhile for black to play
bishop to f5
and after knight to f6 you
you go back to e6
that is definitely worthwhile black has
gained something there right
what is that something well the knight
has been demoted
is it better on g3 or e4
it's definitely better on e4
it's boxed out on g3 no great forward
movements here
the best it could do is simply return to
e4 so that is time well spent to go to
f5
only after flushing the knife back to we
go to e6
from here knight f3
once more an opportunity for black to go
ahead and capture on e5 this is
considered best
it's not what fisher goes forward with i
think he's probably still in this
mindset of
i'm going to keep queens on i'm going
hunting for your king
you could go ahead and chop away on e5
what may be a reason for black to not go
with this
maybe it wasn't as clear
to black or maybe he didn't even want to
see some
some variation where
the bishop can go to c5
not saying in this exact position but it
may be
slightly uncomfortable or
complicated
not not as clear to black
okay
this is still very very good for black
winning
but the decision here not the capture on
e5 instead queen c7
now black is ready to not only break
down the strong pawn on e5 but
we're avoiding the queen exchange
from here queen b1 oddball
no not so natural move this is
supporting some f
5 advance
you can support it by going to c2 or d3
but
maybe at some point
you know the queen could be kicked away
some timely knight b4 move
so she is at least a little bit more
stable
on b1 we might say
okay only at this point do we go ahead
and capture on e5
that's met with f5
and
the reply here is
i believe we can categorize e4 in this
game as a clearance
the bishop wants to have an open
view on the main diagonal
maybe a jumping point by the the knight
or the queen
it's a forceful move that is for sure
but
there was nothing wrong with going ahead
and capturing on f5
this sequence here chopping away and
simply developing that knight that's on
e8 and who knows where the queen goes i
don't know
maybe here and you could start driving
the knight away
okay this is an excellent position for
black i think one of the
continuations here was knight f5
looks kind of weird isn't that knight
hanging
you can pick it back up in this way
and this is an excellent position for
black winning position
it's a huge square
on d3 you can't castle king's side so
easily and if you go queenside that
bishop's gonna probably kill you
okay
nothing wrong with chopping away on f5
in short
from here though it's e4
pawn takes bishop pawn takes knight
g takes f and this next move i really
like um
maybe it's
because i
i'm more positionally minded with the
game
next move here is
f5
um
it seems
it seems on the surface okay isn't this
nice you you just what
you capture on e6 you win upon you open
a file
why did fisher not
play that move
well
f5
takes into account the e4 square that's
the first thing that sticks out to me
maybe right
next to that is the fact that black
keeps a very healthy king side structure
a nice pawn island
a nice secure pawn island of three
and tactically speaking
uh tactically speaking we have this
threat
f4 with the fork
but uh yeah if i'm to assign a primary
function behind b5 f5 excuse me it is to
maintain control over the e4 square
and
black is essentially saying that this
guy right here that's passed is
going to
that is that is passed and uh
over extended will simply be
conveniently
recaptured
there's not going to be a way for
white to really defend that pawn
okay
the approach here is f4 stopping f4 by
black
knight f6
these next moves
we're just developing the pieces
uh this king he's uncastled but he's
trying to you know
provide some defense over the the
bishops that are on
open files
open e file
rip to e1
let's just pause right about
here i'll make one more move
uh
in what way is black
not better
here
uh everything about this position is
really beautiful
perfect coordination
uh
we look at the structures that tips in
black's favor two pawn islands versus
how many
three pawn islands
dead knight on g3 no forward prospects
these guys do have some nice jumps
already has a battery formed
a cornered rook
not good news for white however you
slice it and this
all these factors do what they help pave
the way for
a final
flurry of tactics
what we have here is a position before
submission type of approach
he's accumulated a lot of positional
uh positives
so
pop quiz the only one of this game
uh can you spot fisher's final sequence
here feel free to
pause the video
okay here we go
rook takes bishop
rick takes rook takes rook
king is being pulled out
it's a small investment
no dark square bishop for white
one final move
can you spot it
maybe pause the video once more from
this position see if you could spot
this last move move 23 here we go
okay queen takes f4
and white resigns
so a flashy finish i'm glad fisher
wasn't uh welcome in this in this game
to
uh
having a queen exchange that was
sidestepped uh at least a couple times
and it you know paved the way for this
flashy finish queen takes f4 queen is
poison
that would run into a checkmate in one
how about that
any other options for the white king
if you don't want to walk into the main
one
you have three let's not think too much
about that one the bishop falls with
check
what about that
that's gonna hurt too
we're gonna get that bishop next move
and if the king goes here self pin can
take advantage of that pin with the
check
king here the knight pounces bishop
falls next
and if the king goes here we have a
check
king here and then knight d4
yeah it's not hitting with check here
but it's taking full advantage now of
this pinned bishop
and there's not a way to defend it no
queen d1 the knight has that one covered
so this one is toast
uh however you slice it so
let's have a look at the tail the tape
on this one
here we go and we can see
it's a pretty high quality game by
fisher
what do we have here average centipond
loss
for team white 59 and fisher is at
19.
so as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below
i hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye
you